hi everyone my name is zai
i'm a senior data scientist in krona
today
i'm about to present uh i'm a lego
bricks
this is a machine learning operations
project that i made for
four prevention team within corner
eventually we want to
uh kind of like advertise it globally
within corners so everybody
like at least every data scientist and
every analyst can use that to build a
model
then let's start who am i
well i have this is not very important
um
like i have introduced myself already
but if you want to find me later here's
my
linkedin profile what is clonner
uh for people who haven't heard about
clonner before
or who does not know much about klonop
before
clone is a payment advisor provider and
by the way
you're free to interrupt me anytime or
raise your hand if you have any
questions
uh i would prefer like interactive uh
kind of like
activities rather than leaving q a by
the end
so you can read the hint anytime if i
speak too fast or
anything wrong what is krona uh clonai
is a payment method provider
uh basically if you're shopping online
you usually have to see
some options like you can pay by paypal
you can use your credit card
and cloner provides pay later slicer
and sometimes using clone on card
so it basically have two groups of
users first one is merchants so we're
helping
merchants to uh kind of like secure
uh their items and their money so we
take all the ford and
risk uh kind of like we take all the
foreign risk from
the customer side so the merchants won't
need to
uh care about that they will always get
paid
uh by their order and we also take care
from the customer perspective
we kind of like allow them to pay uh
whenever
they prefer to
so let's check some basic numbers about
klono
in the recent five years krona has been
uh kind of like gradually
grew up as a big union corps in europe
we have markets globally around 17
countries we have 20k
more merchants 3500 more employees
and we have 1 million transactions per
day more than that
and most importantly we have like 10
billion
uh dollars has been evaluated lately
probably even more
here are three our signature products
pay now pay later slicer the basic
concept is we offer you
very quick and smooth check out you only
need to provide a minimal
personal information and running behind
we are taking
all the risk for you and for the
merchants
how can we do that that comes to our
next topic what is fraud
uh like not just in klono like globally
we have
three different kind of like uh
categories of fraud
we have id theft which means someone uh
took your identity ruling your life
who's claiming
himself or herself as you
and we also have some money mirrors we
also have
people who's like intentionally using
wrong information
to taking advantage of the merchants
there are
like kind of like small other concepts
of groups
but in general we have those three main
categories of groups
as i said before krona provides
treatment
payment methods and all of them are
advertising
by smooth payment checkout which means
all the risk of including all of these
three categories for the lens will be
taken care of
by us
uh maybe it's too fast let's go back to
see the category of fraudulence again
because that is kind of like strong
related to the model
so we have addie credit card for abusive
behavior which means you intentionally
want to
uh take advantage of merchants by lying
and you have border id and sometimes we
do have some loopholes
so in four prevention team which is my
current team
one of our main mission
is to fight against fraud
and how are we going to do that so here
is a quick example of clonal
checkout this is a typical phone iframe
uh if you have trouble two uh i can't
makes out bigger
[Music]
but i can explain that so for example
here is a
very common payment method and you only
need to provide your first name last
name
shipping billing address and certain
very very limited information
and at the time you click this button
we are running an advanced model behind
you
and checking if you were a fall or not
so basically this sophisticated decision
engine
uh is made of machine learning models
plus
some binary rules uh and my job here
is to create machine learning models to
increase
both precision and recall like in
purpose of reducing flow rate
as well as uh make sure my customers
have smooth payment experience
and a question so far
great
so now let's talk about like i cannot
like smoothly ease you into the today's
main character
uh amal lego bricks but as i mentioned
before my main job here is to building
machine learning models
then the question naturally raised is
what does data scientists do
and uh like how do we build machine
learning models uh specifically in the
prevent of fraudulence and of course
there are other questions come along
like what are actually machine learning
models and how do i deploy that
how do i evaluate how do i monitor
models
but here in this specific topic i'm only
going to go through the first question
and the third question so what does data
scientist do
and you may think this question is a
little bit offensive because
i'm sure you know what does data science
do because you're the audience or pi
data
however uh this is just to help you
better understand
uh what does amal ligo bricks do
for the later slides so please bear with
me and it's just
the third question how do we build
machine learning models that is more
than
uh kind of like a summarized question
it's supposed to
uh just help you to like quickly refresh
like what are
basic pre requisites we need to build a
machine learning model
that would also be a building block for
ml lego bricks
uh in the further slides
here's the answer uh well
as data scientists um eventually
we are a group of people who's like
applying
operations on data side it can be any
operation but eventually
we are applying a sequence of operations
on data sites
and by sequence i mean uh like
of course you have different options but
you will always
have to start with raw data like
cleaning up then feature selection
then pre-precising and further you can
train
you can tune you can calibrate her
get out a model monitor reporting
further deployment so this is pretty
much the sequence we are always
following
and in each small sequence we always
have
very similar other operations applying
on this part of sequence
do we have any different opinion here
i guess this is a no
let's quickly recap previously on model
building tools
uh the previously is only limited in the
scope
of klono uh i don't speak for other
companies and
other projects so we usually start with
structure notebook for basic
basic eda uh then we move things
uh gradually to a real python project
uh use python rest code like whatever
editor you want to use
that brings some dumb like dark sides
oops dark start
uh repetitive code right every time you
start building
a model you will have to spin off a
notebook instance
and you pretty much check same things
all the time
even though for different data source
even though for different model
you always check the missing rate of the
feature you're always
counting something you always check like
the
pearson correlation towarding uh your
target
and features cramming value basic
statistic over you
you're you're doing this stuff like you
know repeats delay like
day by day every time every project
you start doing this kind of thing and
eventually you have like thousands of
lines of code powered up
in different notebooks that brings to
the second
dark side which is hard to debug if you
are doing all this experimenting on
notebook
notebook is very famous of presenting
pictures and very uh convenience to use
but
uh it has a limitation on cache memory
and it's very hard to debug
you can't you can't go to your code like
very easily with a linking
and there's no test function this is
basically just a
playground and even though after you
move everything from jupiter to a real
python project
you still kind of like moving around
with copy and pasting
there are lots of manual work which you
can avoid off in the first place
that is a previous model building tools
uh
which happened in clona
now let's bring our main character to
the stage
what is on our lego bricks
i'm a lego bricks comprise three
components
and by the way i cannot see any other
audience
except for myself so if anyone has a
question
uh feel free to ask i'm a lego bricks
compulsory components
a code sharing library a stage maker
photo structure
and a cookie cutter template i will dab
into that in the next slides
what are the okay uh
the first one the code sharing library
um
way pretty much built a uh
like a helper library like second learn
with inclona uh on big bucket
which is nothing more than a gate code
management
it's just like we try to make our code
clean
tidy and appropriate
so every single function will have a
test function like everything has been
done properly
and this code sharing library is
fundamentally
important to ml lego bricks but
i'm pretty sure everyday scientists like
experienced data scientists somehow
like always will have like certain
maybe uh 20 to 50
thousand lines of code powered up in
their laptop
eventually they can make their own code
sharing library by
organizing them but here we are talking
about a centralized
code sharing library which has been
created within our team
uh that library will be very important
for our
lego bricks and i will explain
furthermore in other slides
second one is amazon stage maker stage
maker is a
powerful strong team it has so many
layers so many perspectives in our lego
bricks
we are only using training pre-precising
and tuning
for audience who are not super familiar
with stage maker
uh it's fun i can explain into details
later
so far you only need to know this is a
aws
machine learning service and we're
connecting our big bucket
to city maker by using darker image and
ecr
sorry the third component is cookie
carter
this one eventually is only a tool to
help you create a
project and i have a small demo here
just to quickly show you how it down
so here uh we are actually
git clone this cookie cutter data
science project
and in the beginning of this project
there is a template you have created
it will ask you some questions regarding
to
folder's name project's name and
anything you are you can imagine for
example your confidential to advance
what is your target value uh if you want
to
add something like like environment
variables everything can be
created uh as a template
before you create this project and by
using cookie cutter
you can create a project template with
certain
uh predefined variables this one is very
important
because later you will see cookie cutter
works like a
bridge to glue stick maker and big
bucket all together
such that we can create a a
like a template of model by one click
away
if we don't have any questions regarding
to cookie cutter i will move to next
slides but we can always come back to
see this demo again
so cookie cutter
compresses three components then what
kind of benefit comparing with
the dark side with previous model
building tools
we have no more repetitive code because
everything has been moved to the
centralized code sharing library
and we will have standardized model
building cycle
because as i said data scientists
are only applying sequence of operations
again again again on the data side
this building cycle will be standardized
by calling ammo lego bricks
and certainly the crowd sourcing because
armored lego bricks eventually is in
very
low level establishment there is nothing
complicated
nothing fancy everything has been
written by clause and functions with
person
anyone can contribute in this library if
they
um if they are willing to and
certainly oh sorry firstly uh by using
ammo lego bricks
uh like gluing three components together
we allow you to build a model
by one click away and lastly
it's very flexible you can pretty much
cook your own model
and maybe the word cook sounds a little
bit weird but i will
explain later in the next slides but
important thing is
this is very flexible you can plug in
and out
different components different bricks to
have different pipelines
eventually you have different model and
even priority you have different model
running at the same time
and give you different reports and all
of this can be done
by one click
now you may ask me how and
behind every product there's a story i
saw steve jobs said that
google it turns out he didn't so
i guess i said that if if you have
trouble with my weird sense of humor
raise your hand
oh to let's go back to the slides again
uh so you may ask me how um
that actually brings to the main
philosophy
uh behind the unknown lego bricks the
recipes
and ingredients it's it's not a little
bit weird in the first place
uh and it takes me ages to find like a
a better like analogy for for this
concept
uh just to help you better understand
english perspective i gonna begin with
my
uh favorite spaghetti recipe
which is here so everything is pretty
much
inspired and start by uh how to cook
your spaghetti
i know this is dinner time so um bear
with me for
another oh 10 minutes uh
the left side is sherdon's favorite
spaghetti
and the right side is my favorite pasta
you see they have
different recipes and like essentially
there are different great ingredients
but it's not all the ingredients are
different right you always need tomato
and it's not all the methods are
different either you always need to chop
things down
you need olive oil all the time you need
like cream
you need cheese so there are some common
things
between different recipes not just a
method but
also the ingredients
uh so that is how anal lego bricks work
essentially because we treat different
operations
for the model as different small
ingredients
and when we glue those ingredients
together we actually create different
recipes
and this different recipe later on
can be wrapped up and shipped as a
darker image on stitch maker
and eventually we'll have so many
different recipes
you can stack them over or you can just
like select a different thing
then create something very very
different it can be a model it can be
uh i kind of think a better example but
like think about you can have
uh like three engine based algorithm
meanwhile you have deep learning
algorithm all running parallely
uh but all created from the same
bucket of ingredients
i wish i explained that clearly about
the energy like the
real relationship between spaghetti and
i'm not lycopex
again if you have any questions please
feel free to raise your hand
so that idea actually uh inspire us to
think about
can we have a recipe for model building
considering
we have the same model building cycle
all the time and we'll always apply the
same sequence of
operations on the data side let's
quickly recap to the previous slides
on
sorry where is it
um
[Music]
wrong order
oh sorry this is actually the next slide
the same model building cycle let's dab
into
details a little bit we always come from
the raw data
cleaning up then we have a basic
statistic overview
which is eda analysis then we have
feature selection
that pretty much depends on your own
methodology
then we have visual engineering this one
is customized this is totally option
no it depends on you i'm not saying ml
lego bricks does not
include this block but it provides you
options to plug this
in or just plot it out from the whole
model building cycle
afterwards we have privatizing then we
move to train
tune and reporting so this is pretty
much the same more building cycle
anytime and everywhere for all different
machine learning models do i have any
uh different opinion regarding to this
then i will move to next slides
here uh
like depth even into a little bit deeper
to each uh building
block in this whole building cycle so
we see the same operations applied to
uh different blocks again again and
again
for example in the cleaning of
pipeline in this block you always need
to check the data type
for the inspectation you need to
validate your data site
as reliable for the further use for your
model
and in eda you always need to check the
missing right of the feature
covering the shifting moving average
anything which might be useful
for uh model tracking then
to the next pipeline you are actually
like oh
sorry this has been
let me quickly adjust my screen
so in the next step uh for the
pre-precising
you always do the pre-precising
accordingly to different data type
for numerical you need to replace the
missing value input
scalar type casting for arduino
uh you'll probably have a frequency
encoder probably do not
this is optional but i will provide you
this
opportunity to do to do that and for
high
arduino string uh you pretty much do the
wonha encoder and other stuff
um i i'm not going to through every
single operation but i guess you get my
point
for each different building blocks like
here
for each single building blocks if you
dab into there
you pretty much use the same operation
all the time
when you build a new model or rebuild a
old model
so that comes to the question why don't
we
automate everything how come we cannot
uh like have a recipe including these
ingredients
and with a fixed order
but a reasonable order and we have the
recipe
on hand and when the time comes we need
to build a model
we can quickly pull out this recipe then
building the model gonna be one click
away i'm out lego bricks
exactly satisfy this purpose
uh let's start with some
pseudo code so
the concept from like uh recipes right
here in the actual coding uh
perspective each recipe is a combination
of different pipelines so pipeline is a
real
uh coding concept which we abstract from
the same model building cycle here so
each block
is pretty much each pipeline in amount
like our breaks
so here is an example of clean eda
pipeline
and feature engineering pipeline the
only thing we are asking
is the model name and certain parameters
you may ask if each model has certain
different parameters
then how do you automate that and make
sure everybody
can use that as a black box uh the
answer is twofold
firstly every parameter
will be given as a
environment variable or exported
from a constant dot py and how do
we how do how do ml lego
breaks customers know that they will be
offer opportunities to
create or to reform these variables
before they even create the model
project
by using cookie cutter so this part is
how
cookie cutter comes to a picture it
helps you to be
a little bit customized with your own
target
your own variables and some stuff
like very related only related to your
own project
another four of this question is email
lego bricks
is not a black box you can use that as a
black box
because if you don't have any special
requirement
you can pretty much build a model by one
click away with the existing
recipes that we have provided however
uh our idea like the final go
is to help you to be familiar with this
project
and eventually be the owner of this
project we want you to go into this box
and make contribution uh let's quickly
check those
pseudo code uh i have three slides here
which starts from clean eda pipeline so
you see
in each pipeline uh let's take the first
pipeline as example
we are downloading data uh from the
beginning
then we're doing clean then we're doing
edi
for each different method if you
actually go into the code
we have provided so many different
methods for each pipelines to do
different ingredients and eventually you
have different recipes
and for future engineering pipeline
again this one is
totally optional you don't have to do
that but if you want
uh you can just pull out the standard
feature engineering pipeline from ml
lego bricks
which is a utility function transformer
which means you're doing nothing
you can smoothly uh going from cleaning
eda
to the next step
next one is precising this one is a
little bit complicated
because uh the pre-precising actually
depends on the training algorithm
you'll be used in the next step but
uh like in very general overview
we provide you different precision
pipeline
according to three different basic
trade-based engine algorithms
cad boost x-ray boost and likely bm
eventually like i said uh we encourage
people in clona
to implement their own coding block
in this amount legal works so eventually
you can have more different recipes
but this one is the standard recipe like
i'm presenting here
and in the pre-processing pipeline you
can split your data aside
uh and start purposizing there are other
different flags
which help you to do a little bit more
uh
sophisticated work but i'm just not
showing them here
now we come to train uh so
here uh we haven't talked about stage
maker yet because
uh i'm a lego bricks allow you to train
everything on stage maker
but if you don't have aws account that
is fun you can train everything
on your local instance that is allowed
what is important in train pipeline here
is you have different methods again
train calibrator and you have different
calibrator
we provide different algorithms and you
have
performance reporting
and future importance
and a question so far
okay i'll take that aside now i do
appreciate some questions because i want
to
quickly grab some water
but if you guys know yes please yeah uh
i say
i want you to ask them but maybe if you
want to drink water you can ask now
uh did you compare this so nowadays
there is a lot of
automation in this area for example
sagemaker recently
released sage maker pipelines or ml
pipelines there
did you compare with this new offering
from sagemaker i wonder if there
if it gives you more advantages or
disadvantages sir
well uh yes more or less well uh
i guess essentially the difference
between ml lego bricks and
all other automated aml apps
is as far as i know
all the other ammo ops is a black box
and for example if you're using c to
make a pipeline you are pretty much
using their own docker image
and their own training algorithm
everything
belongs to city maker you have
very limited capacity to twist to change
it and to improve that
so eventually i guess for for a fully
automated black box
pipeline it's probably very useful uh
for some companies who are not
yet data science driven
but in other tech companies who are
uh willing or who are ambitious to be
more data science driven
i think it's good to have something like
amalgam breaks
so you can have customized ingredients
which here
customize functions and most important
function is
for example your loss function will
train the model right if you are using
other ml uh operations
it's very hard to achieve that and as
far as i know
like data breaks stage maker pipelines
and ml flows
they're all kind of like uh very
difficult
to set up
uh the right access and talking to
different systems other than yourself
for example if you're using switchmaker
pipelines for all from end to end
it's very hard for you to plot in other
services
that dependency is very difficult to
tackle down
but if you're using aml lego bricks at a
very low
level too everything is clear then you
can pretty much
plug this whole part in on an auto
service
you can wrap up everything as a docker
image ship
it so i think that is a most
uh like different uh
thing between ml lego bricks and other
like a
mature real you know market-wise product
did i did i answer a question yeah
thanks
great answer yeah i agree kind of stage
maker obviously they want to lock you in
their what they provide right and
you cannot much deviate from what they
provide
yeah cool thank you nice
uh any other question
how does collaboration on projects
through uh lego bricks work like
currently in my current setup
we use um meta flow by
by a bit so therefore um is there are
other options to really
include um uh ml lego bricks in this oh
and like a setup like that
uh the meta flow if i would
i use meta flow about one year ago i
don't actually recall
so uh i think megaflow is pretty much
working
very similar to i'm not like operates
right i think the difference is the
scatters
like at each different step meta flow
actually
save the status uh of
the not the model but form from the
pipeline
yeah exactly yeah right so i'm on lego
bricks
has very similar concept but
uh we're not saving the status of the
data we are saving the data schema
because uh the basic philosophy behind
that
is we're always applying operations on
data side
which means at each pipeline you have in
and out
of data side but that in and out
can be simplified just by a schema of
data which is
column's name and the data type
of columns because those two things are
the only things has been changed
during different operations
so instead of like saving the standards
we are saving data schema
by the end of each pipeline for example
the clean eda pipeline after that
i'm going to have a smaller data site
because i'm dropping certain columns
so i will have a json file including all
the existed
features after this pipeline and with
the data type
because sometimes data type will be
twisted
during certain operations you probably
treat the boolean
as a numerical number somehow in some
function
so at each step if it's necessary
we generate and export a data
uh schema which also helps us to go back
and forth we don't have to
if there's anything wrong in the middle
we don't have to go back to
cleaning the pipeline we don't have to
go back to the first function download
data
we can go to any step and start over
from
start start over from there because we
have data schema saved
we can uh reload the whole data source
you don't have to but
if you want you can reload the data site
and apply the data schema
got the smaller data side then move on
from there
did i answer your question yeah
absolutely
thanks no worries
okay let's go to the next slide
considering
i only have one minute left
uh okay so now
how does stitchmaker come to a picture
again please bear with my
weird sense of humor i just love this
slogan you know
uh sorry how do i go to
so shipping model recipe to stage maker
that is how stage maker
comes to this picture every single
pipeline
can be shipped as a darker image to
uh ecr then switchmaker can take over
from there
and how do i make that
reliable and consistent and
automated very simple
we can use this a
a great decision maker for the structure
again for people who's not very familiar
with switchmaker
uh there are so many things this is very
very overwhelming so i will
cut everything only tell you the most
important thing
think about that if you're using stage
maker uh
which pretty much means you are reading
data saving data like everything
everything regarding to data
communication is in extreme bucket
and siege maker by default
has a folder structure uh
this is not exactly the the correct
definition because there is no
data past the actual path in either in
iso bucket or decision maker but just
let's bear with this wrong concept at
the moment
so in sleep maker for different uh
job training sorry pre-precising
training and tuning
you will be monitored default by
different folder paths
and inevitably you need to have the same
mounted
volume pass on x3 bucket
as long as you agree with us like the
the final pass of the data in and out
for example the data schema i have
mentioned before
and other stuff then uh we're good to go
you don't need to do
anything this folder structure will be
created
when you create your model project by
using cookie cutter
there is nothing you need to take care
of except for
your own advice confidential and that
would be
the environment variable you are given
to corey carter
in the first place we are only asking
you to agree
with us that will be the folder
structure
in your actual bucket and we will create
that for you
any questions
then let's go to next slides
uh this actually has already been
covered
uh what does cookie cutter actually do
here
um well i guess quick cutter
serves two purposes and this is kind of
like
specific to clona because eventually we
need to deploy the model somewhere
and at the moment we still
want to have a full model structure like
like
full model project sitting somewhere
for tracing back and forth for
monitoring
for uh better understanding so in this
case
netherlands we need to create a model
project
uh cookie cutter comes with a picture
because uh this is
very handy to use and
uh because i'm out lego bricks only
asking for
certain variables uh it's it's
it's it's very easy to create a template
with a quick cutter so you can just like
read that uh as a create determiner
feature
before you even start building a model
but secondly uh with quick cutter
you're actually um like
gluing the code sharing library and the
stage maker together
uh because you're gonna have some
scripts
running model like running a pipeline
from end to end
right so for example if i go back to the
pseudo code
this is only like two pipelines here
when you're actually running your model
since you have options to to gluing them
together by different orders or
different ways
you still need to have you still need to
have a script somewhere
by using cookie cutter we actually
created a different template
of scripts uh gluing those pipelines
differently with different
uh proper sizing algorithm and different
training algorithm
those are kind of like a pre-site
project
in this way that actually allows people
to have
different options to cook their model so
that is how cookie cutter
comes to the picture
any questions
here are like two examples of uh what
does cookie cutter json file looks like
and what does
it actually do so for example here i'm
asking certain things that were needed
for this model
uh because i'm using i'm actually
treating this model on stage maker so i
need my
device credentials and those are cookie
cutter json file
uh included which means one create my
model project
by using cookie cutter the template that
i have
created every time i will be asking
what is your system id what are your
name space tag what is the profile
and those features are these parameters
are different
according to different team right uh you
can set up
that as a template for different team or
you can just like answer these questions
every time you need to create a model
project
after you answer this question currently
there will be a a dot in file created
according to this
carter.json which pretty much just
extracting
all the parameters you have just been
given then
set up like a device configuration for
you
that's it it's only very it's only for
convenience
but not just for convenience because
cool color is also very
very powerful this is only the
tip of the aspect
questions um
can you provide a little bit details how
does it run inside of sagemaker
is it like the whole pipeline is a
single training job or do you split it
somehow by different steps
very good very good question it actually
depends on you
uh you can wrap up different pipelines
into one recipe which means like after
you wrap up this one recipe you can
you can you can ship it as one docker
image on stage maker
then you can trim everything from end to
end in one darker image
on sequencer however uh you can also
uh because let's go back to the
model building cycle a little bit
so raw data cleans the tcru feature
selection
everything prior to feature selection is
kind of like
fixed right when you start creating the
model so
even though you're trying different
things on creating the model
like the three steps over there are
pretty much fixed so in this case
you can create a docker image but only
have
clean eda pipeline ship that decision
maker
trigger stitch maker job get the result
save that somewhere
and in the following steps you can
always start from that point
and from that point if you want you can
wrap every
everything from feature selection to
report in one docker image
uh ship to stage maker uh with training
or have a primary tuning job this is
like all the options if you don't want
to
you can have different stage maker sorry
you can have different docker image
according to different blocks and ship
them one by one
on stage maker and trigger the job one
by one
because you probably want to see uh like
something differently in the middle
did i answer your question yeah sounds
great and maybe one short question
uh you showed like internal folder
structure of sagemaker
does it like what if because it's black
box what if
this folder structure changes does it
mean you have to
figure this out again and propagate it
to your cookie cutter template or
oh no this one is fixed this one like
like if you're using ammo lego bricks
which means you agree with
us your folder structure will be always
looking this way so you will always have
this is actually a little bit out of
date but you will always have your for
example
uh your raw data under
a camp folder because all this like all
the folder paths
were uh pre-defined in
i'm a lego bricks pipeline that's why we
need you to
uh agree with this stage maker folder
structure
but uh if if if you don't want
to uh follow the same structure
there's one way you can do to quickly
change it
which is to have every single folder
name
as a constant and export it from
constant.py
which which which which is the file will
use for
uh reduce some manual work but i
i i would not uh
recommend using that for the
complexities because
this is just a folder structure like
siege maker itself
already have a default uh folder
structure for example the opt
ml uh the opt
ml slash pre-precision
i i couldn't recall so i think it's
quite
common and reasonable to ask our
uh customers followers in structure as
we
recommended
okay sounds good and just one comment
about siege maker being a black box
uh we looked into hosting stage maker
trained models in
another platform and when talking to
sagemaker teams actually said
uh what they put on the docker images is
not secret so they can provide it
i don't know if they provide it nowadays
on public
access but you can actually ask someone
they will
provide like what they what dependencies
they install their place
so you can train and using even using
siege maker training algorithm
and you can ship it somewhere else but
yeah of course they prefer you to post
models
inside of switch maker okay okay i see
okay uh yeah like sometimes
aws uh infrastructure is a little bit
uh kind of like funny uh
i mean they are grateful like powerful
they are very very strong tools
but um sometimes the inner
environment is kind of like uh still a
little bit
uh a black box to me uh for example why
use the namda function i need to create
if i want to upload something new
i need to create a brandy new
virtual environment and sometimes it
does
it does not work you just have to use
your own stuff
and that really ignores me sometimes
so i i'm just like trying to use like
the uh
like they're i i'm just trying to
combine
like all the good things together but
also have
a little bit opportunities to uh
to customize stuff uh like in favor of
our our own requirement not
100 rely on uh the third party service
so i i i guess that is
uh like the deep deep down uh motivation
of me to to using this product because
i'm able to
improve it maintain that and
collaborating with other colleagues
we have a chance to make that better but
we are not
saying no to other good stuff we are
just trying to
uh collaborating with other good stuff
but not entirely like relying on them
okay thank you alright any other
question
um i mean in the meantime if everyone is
thinking about the question i was
wondering about i mean this tool now is
internal in clara right so
everyone could use it internally do you
plan to
make it public at some point i mean you
shared with us a lot of things now so i
guess
at some point of course i want to make
that open source but uh it's
it's quite complicated um i'm
i'm not sure how it would go
if we don't have any questions i want to
show my last slides which is the last
but
it's important i want to give credit to
my colleagues
i want to thank my colleagues which are
four engineerings
who actually initiated a product named
ml pipeline
that is actually the alpha version of ml
lego bricks
the concept is not entirely the same but
uh they did a lot of research behind and
at the same time uh ml flow got created
so their projects got abandoned but we
do learn a lot from their
ml pipelines uh those are four engineers
inclona um and i got their linkedin
profile
uh i i yeah but
just feel free to contact them if you
have any
questions uh and my teammate anil he's
not here i guess but uh he implemented
vex library in amal lego bricks the like
initial version
like i created is only using pandas and
numpy for the data
uh wrangler right uh but a new
implemented vex which is particularly
good with huge form of data
even on local instance uh it's a very
complicated implementation because you
need to
uh pretty much need to uh fix all the
conflicts with nonpartisan pandas
so great work even though he's not here
and
i want to sing to my manager yes they're
also not here but i want to give them
credits because
uh they allow me to put efforts and
spend time on my lego bricks
also help me to reform my slides uh
just in case i lick any confidential
information in like about klono well
that's
it thanks for uh joining me and
thanks for having me here thanks chris
inviting me to give this presentation
uh thank you very much sideways it was
really interesting and also
the questions afterwards were really
nice and um
i just i wanted before before going all
uh i'm just sharing now we have a slack
channel
for the pi data cyprus community in case
you want to join and
maybe have more of this kind of high
quality and more
technical but awesome discussions please
please join this
dislike channel and with that if there
are no more questions
uh thanks thanks again sai and
hope to see you again in the future in
some of the pi data cyprus
talks thank you
okay